Okay, how many days should someone back off taking their antioxidants after receiving chemo?
Are there any other supplements that should be withheld for a time?
So we do have a blog post about this that gives you some general considerations.
Now, understand, there are a lot of alternative practitioners that say,
don't back off at all doing antioxidants. Don't change your supplement protocol at all.
So, you know, you do want to pray about it. You know, my belief is that, you know,
chemo is a strong antioxidant agent. And you know, you want it to work as best as possible.
So I do think you know, you should lay off your antioxidants at least for 48 hours.
And are there other supplements that should be withheld? Maybe you could lay off all your supplements
for 48 hours. There wouldn't be any problem with that at all. You don't want to be doing a lot
of strong detox for that 48 hours because you want chemo to stay in you for that 48 hours and work
and kill the cancer. So you would not be a miss and just stay off of everything for 48 hours
after that chemo. And if you're going to do a fast prior to the chemo, you may stay off
everything during that 24 or 48 hour fast prior to the chemo. There is nothing wrong with doing that.
But I also don't think that there's necessarily anything wrong with the approach. Another
practitioner is taking not to get weight off anything at all. You just need to pray about that.
My personal feeling is I was going to do the chemo. I would go off the antioxidants
during my fast prior to the chemo. And then for 48 hours after the chemo, and I wouldn't do any
coffee enemas. And I wouldn't do you know, strong detox support and lay off of that. So
I may actually lay off of everything for that 48 hour window. And then you could go back
to the chemo. And then you could go back to the chemo. And then you could go back to the chemo.